happy WWDC 2023 I am here I just checked
in I've got my little bag and I'm gonna
head in and hopefully find some of my
other YouTuber Tech friends so let's go
[Music]
thank you so much
oh my gosh what a surprise
Okay so we've got our little WWDC bag
here let's see what's inside okay we've
got some pins like check these out oh my
God
all right we've also got a hat look at
this we'd love to see it a little
tumbler for coffee
oh my gosh this is so nice
we've got our little wwc logo okay
that's all that's in the bag but this
has also got this awesome little tote
love it
[Music]
I love your face oh my gosh I was like
okay am I farming or am I reviewing Tech
today no I mean it's perfect I didn't
even recognize you walking up but it is
like I think this is a new era for you
maybe I don't know I'm not sure I love
it so much thank you good to see you
good to see you oh my gosh I'm so
excited so it's official it's officials
there is in La I saw you posting you're
like wait a minute I told them two
months ago I told it on their podcast
and I totally forgot so the the same
brain fam got it first they did well I
was so excited that you're you're in the
area so we're gonna hang out I have
friends and that's new for me I also
want to tell you that I bought a
basketball pump so we are ready to play
basketball oh my gosh I'm so excited I'm
not good though okay I'll teach you okay
all right
happy birthday thank you so much I mean
is this not the most exciting birthday
ever this is the best 50th birthday I
can imagine I cannot imagine being
anyone else this is crazy so great
everybody go tell them happy birthday
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to what's going to be the best
WWDC ever
the event just ended I'm so overwhelmed
like it was one of the longest events I
feel like everything happened so quickly
it was just like rapid fire Vision Pro
Vision Os Oh my God are you guys like
are you free now
good to see you I only saw you in
passing earlier but yeah thank you thank
you Twitter is like very different
rhetoric and I was like Twitter's like
dystopian like the mask what do you
think like so bitter excited a little of
both absolutely it looks like ready
player one like that movie in real life
I was telling Faruk I was like it kind
of feels like Black Mirror but like I'm
here for it you know what do you think
it's gonna be amazing yeah yeah so I
guess we don't need our screens anymore
you know well I was thinking how cool
would be because I have like a three
monitor setup how incredible would that
be to edit like yes
anything anywhere now you can put the
clips somewhere else and just look at
the screen I'm just hoping that it's
comfortable because if it's not
comfortable you're not going to want to
wear it but I do feel like if Apple's
gonna do something they're gonna do it
right but we question how they're gonna
do FaceTime and then they show that
they're going to do FaceTime minutes
like a digital Persona of yourself but
it actually looked pretty good so I hope
it'll kind of pull through yeah
I've been having the absolute best day
ever
Apple actually made a little Creator
studio so you could go in and record so
I just recorded my little video for my
WBC recap and it was so much easier than
having to go film that in my hotel room
and also this granola mix that they have
it might be the best trail mix I've ever
had good job Apple
look there's dates in there dates and
white chocolate chips
so good I just left my camera in there
and panicked had to go back super sad
thank you thank you
see him from afar you just keep seeing
your friends from afar and you wave as
they go off to their briefings but man
it's so fun getting a chance to actually
try the vision headset was pretty
incredible I keep calling it Vision Plus
for some reason but it's Vision Pro and
it's pretty freaking cool now Tyler and
I have to go do a lot of editing
Tyler's up there look at your cool
headphones dude
these pretty cool dude what are they cos
Porter Pros they look vintage I was like
okay I don't know if these are like a
new thing or it's some sort of like
futuristic vintage but I think that's
yeah they're new they look old but
they're new yeah yeah it is snack time
at the Steve Jobs theater adjacent to
the visitor center look at all these
yeah
oh my gosh hello Michael Josh
you're dub dub going so far ah I I was
just you know I was live tweeting and
taking notes all the whole time until
they announced Vision Pro and then I was
like you know what I think I just need
to soak it in a little bit because this
is a historic historical moment me Sarah
and Julia had to go to the bathroom at
the Midway point I was like oh my God we
might miss the headset but we ran okay
we made it thankfully I I just think
we're gonna look back after a few years
unless I was there and you know what
Apple they always say apple you need
Apple to do it well exactly and then I
think the whole world can follow I've
always believed that the future is
having this layer above our real world
but I love that you can have that and
then you can also just disappear did you
get a demo not yet not yet I'm really
excited no no no just just embrace it
and it's so so wild because it feels
like you're looking at the real world
but yet like your eyes was it easy
because it's a new way of like doing
things so you just know what to do you
just knew what to do once they told you
like to pinch and then you like pinch to
zoom and drag and like it's just it's so
intuitive it was honestly unbelievable I
cannot believe like I will go out and
buy it as soon as I can I can't wait
next year can't come soon enough I know
we still have to have a new iPhone out
first I know the other thing that was
really cool is they didn't really make a
big deal about it but it's connected to
a battery pack so yes the battery pack
lasts two hours but when you go and see
how cool the battery pack is it's like
this aluminum little pack I would love
that part of my iPhone can you guys make
one of these so that you can use as a
charger today you have people on planes
with their big airpods Max right and
their cans to kind of cancel out the
noise now like just imagine like if
you're sitting in coach right flying
spirit and you want to just block out
the real world you have the noise
cancellation and then you can have those
that that like what is it 180 180
degrees does it feel like you're in
somewhere more Zen which is super cool
though because they do have some like
immersion experience yes where it's full
36 years like you look around and you're
just like I'm in it yeah and I like the
mental health like the visualization so
I can actually not have to necessarily
close my eyes right but they disappear
from the world a little bit it was so
awesome
I love the dad dude like he was working
and then his his son his son came over
yeah and then he was able to kick the
ball and like be immersed but also be
present yeah which I think is so
important for like something like this
this is our future yeah I'm here for it
I'm here for it I need it now now so I
actually can't believe it but Vision Pro
is right here it is behind me it's so
cool because we're actually getting a
chance to see it now I did get a chance
to get Hands-On with it and really
experiencing this in real life was by
far way cooler than I really thought it
was gonna be obviously I thought it was
going to be cool but just seeing the way
that this has the ability to really
transport you from your living room into
an entirely new universe was
I'm speechless
foreign
[Music]
this is the battery pack that connects
to the headset and this will give you
about two hours but there is a USBC port
on it that will allow you to connect it
to power so you can use it all day
without worry the actual headset
material is very soft and it really does
form to your head the material is super
lightweight but the actual headset does
have some weight to it so I'm not sure
if this is something that I could wear
all day long but a few hours here and
there with some breaks I definitely
could see myself doing that on top of
the Vision Pro are two buttons and this
is the digital Crown which kind of looks
like the digital crown on the Apple
watch what sets this apart from other
devices like it is the eye tracking and
the selection there are no controllers
there's nothing attached to you because
of the sensors here on the bottom you
could have your hands easily resting in
your lap and with a slight pinch motion
of your two fingers that's how you make
a selection the actual viewing
experience when this is on your your
head is unbelievable the way that this
can seamlessly take you from one
incredible fully immersed world back
into an augmented reality of you sitting
in your living room is pretty impressive
sitting there and having my entire Apple
ecosystem appear before my eyes in my
space in a virtual reality setting was
unlike anything that I'd really ever
experienced before going into messages
going through photos watching 3D movies
and then getting up off of the couch and
interacting with a dinosaur that just
broke through my wall it really felt
like I was transported to another world
now the price tag of this Vision Pro is
3 500 which is pretty expensive it's not
just a headset apple is calling it a
spatial computer it's not connected to
anything separate everything is
happening inside of the headset it's
powered by a dual chip design that
combines an M2 Chip with a brand new R1
chip and the R1 is basically designed to
handle all this real-time sensor
processing while I don't think that
everyone in the world is going to be
going out in I'm purchasing this headset
right now this is laying the groundwork
for developers and content creators to
start making content for this device
having this be announced at WWDC is also
giving developers the entire freedom to
let their imaginations go wild having
the support of Disney Plus on day one of
launch is also really Incredible Disney
has such an amazing catalog of content
plus Star Wars Marvel and more all of
this is leading to Future devices that
could be more cost effective small
better battery life and who knows what
else this my friends is just beginning
[Music]
t-shirts now there is a Ted lasso
exclusive happening now at the Apple
Store and I'm kind of excited but I also
haven't finished season one yet so I
don't really get the reference but I'm
still going to give t-shirt and a jersey
and maybe a hoodie and then after I
watch it I'm gonna be like wow I'm so
glad I bought this so it's pretty cool
should we get this one and I'm also
gonna get the blue
it's a nice hoodie like it's it's pretty
nice
sit
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yeah oh my God I love it it's so like
the color is perfect it's actually a
perfect fit I wanted a small but it's
even nice
oh big nice big Hood a nice Hood
oh this is my airport FIT tomorrow
[Applause]
oh man okay so we had such a long day
today and now I'm back at the hotel I
got a shower I'm in my jammies and
ordered some steaks from a nearby
restaurant from doordash and the side
dishes like look how much food is here
this is ridiculous
um Tyler's got his little meal here this
is gonna be so freaking good and I'm I
just I can't wait to eat and edit in bed
look
how much
and wow okay this is the buffet welcome
to it and here you are
oh yeah oh help yourself good morning I
barely slept I think maybe three hours
packed this morning got up super early
around 5 30. the fact that this suitcase
has closed is an actual miracle I
couldn't have even filmed myself closing
it because the things that I had to do
felt illegal but it's closed and I want
to show you this little tip that I have
for bringing a blanket normally I also
bring a full bed pillow and I wrap it in
a yoga mat strap so that it's easy to
carry and because it's like a pillow and
a blanket and it is kind of large they
usually don't say anything because I'm
like this is my bed this is my sleep I
need this let me live my life I also
take a lot of overnight flights so that
point they're just like okay let's just
let her be she looks unwell so today I
have some more briefings at Apple and
then I'm flying back to Los Angeles so
we're gonna get a little breakfast and
head over to the campus I've been loving
this Ally my video should be posted soon
if it's not already I'm stepping on
something I've been playing Diablo 4. I
freaking love Diablo so much so it's
been awesome to be able to take this on
the go so as long as I have Wi-Fi I'm
able to connect I do wish there was some
more offline play for some of the games
that I like but it is what it is
croissanti time
plans to make like a really cool Montage
of my last day at Apple and then my
flight home that did not in fact happen
I fell asleep the second that I got on
that plane I did not wake up until that
plane landed it was like freaking time
travel I am so exhausted this is my oral
ring sleep score from last night that's
pretty high and if you'll notice that
little blue line is completely solid
that means I didn't move at all this is
it looks like a normal sleep I move
around a lot and the dog was even in my
bed no there was I was in an absolute
coma um anyway I had so much fun at
Apple but I have got to film in a little
bit
so I'm gonna just continue resting here
for a little while until I have to be to
be a person
oh goodbye